alors juste pour prendre un petit temps
je suis le dernier intervenant chez pas
besoin de la télécommande
merci juste pour avoir une idée là ce
que vous pouvez levez la main ceux qui
passent une bonne soirée ça me donnera
une idée
ok alors j'avais préparé plein de choses
pour ce soir j'ai changé plusieurs fois
ma présentation et puis finalement j'ai
décidé de venir avec rien du tout ou
plutôt avec moi et de parler on vient de
parler de chirurgie de venir vous parler
avec mon coeur donc opération à coeur
ouvert ce soir avec vous donc pas que je
fasse deux grandes confidences désolé
mais vous présenter un petit peu mon
travail
et avant de vous présenter mon travail
je crois que j'aimerais vous parler un
petit peu de moi comme chacun d'entre
nous ici ce soir d'un an vient chacun
avec notre histoire et puis notre
héritage alors moi j'ai grandi dans une
famille on va dire privilégier
j'ai toujours à manger dans mon assiette
j'ai toujours à manger pour mon coeur
d'ailleurs j'ai hérité d'un bon coup de
fourchette que ce soit pour les
nourritures du ventre les nourritures du
coeur et puis donc moi s'il ya quelque
chose qui m'a marqué fort et je pense
que ça a conditionné les souder des
choix de vie à mon adolescence et puis
dans le métier que je mène aujourd'hui
j'ai vécu comme un décalage fort je
vivais dans un appartement il ya une
grande porte en fer forgé et qui a été
un que j'ai découvert en fait assez
tardivement qui est devenue symbolique
pour moi à l'intérieur donc du côté
intérieur de la porte c'était le monde
du dedans et c'était le monde chaud le
monde aimant le monde sécurisant vous
pouvez vivre ma vie d'enfant avec
l'innocence qui le caractérise et puis
le monde du dehors de l'autre côté de la
porte et ben c'était la réalité du monde
dans toute sa diversité avec des choses
merveilleuses et puis des choses moi qui
m'ont qui m'ont assez marquées fort
enfants j'ai encore l'image d'un petit
garçon qui vivait à côté de chez moi je
vers 9-10 ans à l'époque et puis ce
petit garçon bas je le voyais il était
mal habillé sa zone ça se voyait qu'il
avait des des carences et je le voyais
de temps en temps ramené son père livre
chez lui à la maison
c'est une mare des images comme ça
qu'ils m'ont marqué très fort et qui ont
fait émerger chez moi des grands
questionnements mais pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi et des gens qui vivent qu'ils
sont bien et pourquoi y'a des gens qui
viennent et qui sont pas bien donc il ya
eu un mélange comme ça d' émotion assez
forte et je pense qu'à cette époque là
en tout cas à l'adolescence j'ai
développé une maladie qui est la honte
la honte en fait de avoir moins un des
parents aimants un cadre structurant
toujours à manger à la maison
et puis et puis cette honte et c'est
mélanger avec la culpabilité avec de la
colère la rage avec un grand cris de
mais pourquoi 1 pourquoi le pourquoi
tout le monde a pas moi ce que j'ai quoi
donc à demander à mon adolescence à
massa m'a emmené dans des dans une
descente aux enfers moment pour
paraphraser mon collègue thomas dans ce
bourg j'ai commencé à fréquenter voilà à
passer du temps avec des jeunes va qui
vivait eudes en grande souffrance et
dans des environnements très violents et
je pense que c'était une manière pour
moi de vienne mettre du baume sur mon
coeur d'une certaine manière ben voila
je suis comme vous je suis avec vous et
puis on partage les mêmes souffrances et
d'une certaine manière à ce moment là
pour moi l'équilibré il a été retrouvé
entraînement dans la suite et il ya un
événement il y en a eu beaucoup
je pense que l'amour et la confiance que
j'ai reçu de mes parents même quand la
confiance elle n'était pas là a été très
forte
et puis à un événement qui a été
marquant pour moi parmi d'autres je me
souviens un jour mon père il est venu je
sais plus qui s'était passé mais c'était
difficile pour eux d'être témoin de ce
que je vivais et un jour il est venu
s'asseoir par terre dans ma chambre
et puis à ce moment là bas il m'a ma
partager toute la tristesse toute la
peine qu'il avait sur le coeur sans
reproche ni critique et ça waouh ça a
été du lourd pour moi à ce moment là et
c'est pas seulement une rencontre entre
le père et le fils que ça a permis à ce
moment là c'est vraiment une rencontre
de choeur à coeur et c'est plus tard que
je me suis rendu compte vraiment de la
puissance et du pouvoir de la
vulnérabilité et c'est un petit peu de
ça que j'ai envie de vous parler de ce
soir la communication non violente s'est
pas seulement dans des situations
tragiques de la vie et en appelant des
situations tragiques d'ailleurs je pense
que ce qui m'a donné de l'espoir et de
l' envie d'aller dans cette voie
c'était de voir cette marshall rosenberg
qui a été l'initiateur de cette approche
travailler avec des communautés
ethniques qui était en conflit avec dans
une même salle des gens qui sont
entretués voilà qui a tué la mère de
l'autre qui a vu les donc des
circonstances vraiment dramatique est
que dans ces circonstances-là 10 arrivée
avec un travail et surtout beaucoup d'
écoute de patience et de bienveillance à
trouver à retrouver un équilibre de
l'harmonie entre les personnes donc il
ya des circonstances tragiques et puis
il y en a d'autres il ya des petites
choses qu'on vit dans notre quotidien
qui nous pourissent un peu la vie et
puis voilà comme comme le disait tout à
l'heure voilà barça peut être dans le
coup dans l'entreprise dans la famille
moi j'ai une petite fille de deux ans et
dit des choses horribles comme non c'est
dur à vivre des fois c'est dire la vie
donc la communication non violente s'est
pas seulement pour pour gérer des
conflits
c'est aussi pour s'embellir la vie au
quotidien donc pour ceux qui ont des
petits enfants sachez qu'à l'âge de deux
ans les enfants disent beaucoup non en
fait ils disent pas non
ils disent oui ils disent oui à leur
singularité et en fait personne ne dit
jamais non
on dit tous oui à quelque chose et un
besoin qui est propre
donc ça peut acheminer pour vous pour ce
qu'on descend forme
voilà donc la communication non-violente
d'où ça vient donc j'ai dit c'est ça a
été créé par ce monsieur qui s'appelle
marshall rosenberg qui a été qui s'est
inspiré un beaucoup de démarches porté
par gandhi martin luther king donc des
hommes quand on promet la non-violence
dans l'eure
nord on va discuter ce moment-là social
et humain et puis il a été psychologique
l'initiant il a quitté la psychologie
clinique parce qu'il en avait assez de
mettre des étiquettes sur des gens et
s'est rendu compte que de dire à
quelqu'un qu'il est schizophrène ou par
la riaa coupe si les psychotiques salle
est pas forcément à guérir il s'est
orienté vers des cours un courant de
psychologie qu'on appelle la psychologie
humaniste dont un des grands pères
fondateurs et carl rogers qui a
développé tous ces concepts d'empathie
en tout cas au niveau des sciences de la
psychologie d'empathie dégoûte actifs
quand on entend parler des coûts de
centrée sur la personne d' écoute active
et d'empathie
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments qui
viennent de cette approche là voilà donc
pour revenir à cette histoire que j'ai
pu vivre avec mon père ça c'est
peut-être un autre message j'ai envie de
passer soit je pense que les jeunes
aujourd'hui en tout cas moi ça a été mon
cas mon expérience bas on arrive dans un
monde qui est pas forcément très joyeux
et des fois je me dis vraiment en tant
qu'adulte qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
pour offrir et accueillir nos enfants
dans des meilleures conditions quoi et
par rapport à ça pour les parents des
adolescents les adolescents ne sont pas
en crise
il cherche la lumière et pour revenir
donc à cette expérience avec mon père je
crois que ce soir sans ce soir là sans
le vouloir et sans le savoir il m'a
partager un grand secret le secret des
alchimistes le secret qui permet de
transformer ce qui plombe en or et le
secret de ce qui peut transformer ce qui
nous plombe en or pour moi ce soir là
c'était la bienveillance et je vois que
dans notre manière d'être en relation
avec nous mêmes et en relation avec les
autres on a pas on prend rarement le
temps d'écouter dans notre coeur ce qui
se passe on parlait ce soit en
introduction que cette soirée c'est les
explorateurs j'ai parcouru le monde dans
plein d'endroits j'ai pas été partout
reste encore beaucoup à faire
je vois que le chemin des fois le plus
périlleux et le plus long c'est celui
qui nous mène de la tête au coeur
et je dis ça parce que je vois qu'on vit
dans un monde de représentation on est
un peu dans une dictature de la
représentation chacun a ses opinions
chacun ses représentations du monde avec
ses valeurs avec avec ses points de vue
avec ses jugements sur les situations et
on est finalement toujours à se
rencontrer dans nos représentations et
finalement évidemment comme on est on
est tous différents avec des
représentations du monde qui sont
différentes pour chacun et bah ya
rarement des moments où on arrive à se
rencontrer à se rejoindre
ce que permet la communication non
violente c'est de voyager d'aller au
delà de nos représentations pour pouvoir
nous rejoindre
donc j'étais un petit peu ennuyés parce
que je me disais ce soir je me dis ben
voila j'ai envie de partager la
communication non violente et dans mon
travail je mets beaucoup d'attention à
ce que chacun puisse vivre une
expérience je me rends compte que c'est
comme si je venais un petit peu vous
parlez d'une randonnée est 100 ans en
vous emmener avec moi sur le chemin quoi
donc c'est un petit peu un défi je vais
quand même vous donner quelques éléments
la première chose qu'on tente de faire
en communication non violente c'est
justement de faire la distinction entre
nos représentations au point de vue nos
idées nos vues nos opinions et ce qui
est du factuel
je peux prendre un petit exemple simple
ainsi je suis élèves dans une classe et
puis quand l'enseignant me dit que je
suis pas sérieux que je tient pas en
place que il faut que je me calme
à ce moment là donc il est dans le
jugement dans la représentation dans la
critique et à ce moment là
moi j'ai du mal à me représenter en tant
qu'enfant qu'est ce qui est important
pour le pour l'enseignant ce que
j'entends c'est la critique donc ça peut
générer de la fermeture je sais pas
comment vous le vivez vous quand
quelqu'un vient vous faire un reproche
une critique en général on a du mal à
ouvrir grand le coeur et puis diront oui
je vois bien ce que tu veux dire je
comprends ce qui est important pour toi
plutôt tendance à 11 entrées soit dans
la justification soit dans l' attaque et
donc est ce qu'elle nous permet la
communication non-violente ça va être
déjà d'être de bien distinguer ce qui
est de l'ordre du subjectif
un de mes représentations et ce qui est
de leurs de l'objectif du factuel là
typiquement si je reprends l'exemple
dans la classe va peut-être qu'à un
moment donné je me suis levé où j'ai
jeté mon stylo sur sur un autre élève un
sas et les faits la critique le jugement
le subjectif c'est il est pas sérieux il
tient pas en place et sait pas se tenir
il respecte pas ses camarades et qu'est
ce qu'on va faire alors eh ben c'est une
chose simple une fois qu'on a fait déjà
la distinction entre les faits et ce que
je veux me raconte
eh ben je vais aller goûter ce que je me
raconte est en général toute notre
attention elle est focalisé sur ce que
l'autre ne fait pas de bons et là plutôt
que de focaliser mon attention sur
l'autre eh ben je vais tourner le
projecteur à l'intérieur et puis je vais
regarder
qu'est ce que ça me fais moi quand je
vois ça donc si je prends l'exemple de
cet enseignant ca est de dire bah
peut-être d'un mois j'en peux plus quoi
j'en peux plus j'ai trente élèves devant
moi j'aimerais tellement arrivé au bout
de vos bouts de ma séance
et puis là je sais juste pas comment
faire quand quand alexis jette son stylo
dans le visage de l'autre et puis je me
sens un peu démuni mais j'aimerais avoir
du soutien parce que j'ai besoin
j'ai besoin d'une certaine attention
pour pouvoir faire mon programme
c'est ma fille pour que la communication
demande qu'est ce qu'elle va nous
inviter à faire essentiellement ca se
mettra les gouttes
mais qu'est ce qui va nous permettre de
se mettre à l'écouté c'est de pouvoir
regarder les choses avec un certain ce
que j'appellerais un détachement
passionnés c'est à dire à la fois avec
de la distance
une distance qui va me permettre
d'éviter de m'identifier d'une certaine
manière
et puis passion c'est à dire les
curiosités amour et bienveillance et
c'est cette qualité de présence et
d'écouté qui va me permettre
d'identifier ce qui est en jeu pour moi
chaque instant parler de la violence au
début la violence marshall dizaine chose
qui me va beaucoup aider à rejoindre
l'autre dans des moments où j'ai du mal
à comprendre pourquoi ils réagissaient
comme ça pourquoi il fait ça des fois ça
me choque et même la violence est
l'expression tragique ou maladroite d'un
besoin non satisfait d'ailleurs chaque
comportement
il ya un besoin qui est en jeu un besoin
universel un besoin c'est une force
fondamentale de vie qu on partage tous
en tant qu'être humain et donc de
comprendre ça moi je vois que ça ça
m'aide énormément dans ma vie
à m déjà apprendre à me connaître et
puis en plus d'apprendre à me connaître
à pouvoir développer ma capacité à
pouvoir rejoindre l'autre dans ce qui
vit dans ce qui se passe pour lui alors
pour terminer j'aimerais dire juste une
dernière chose c'est que à un moment
donné je pense que si on a vraiment
envie d'arriver à se rencontrer dans
notre singularité que ce soit dans des
moments conflictuelles ou des dom dans
des moments voilà du quotidien de la vie
est bien pour pouvoir se rencontrer dans
notre singularité d'une chose qui peut
nous aider c'est de se rejoindre un
endroit où on partage tous la même
humanité
je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté